we have great intentions we want to be
healthier we want to live into our 70s
80s and '90s
free of of
disease but we're kind of you know we're
distracted there's a lot of shiny
objects we're jumping from this to that
we're not really measuring things
objectively and I liken that to throwing
darts at a a dartboard with the lights
off how good are we going to be at
hitting the target if the lights are off
and so the idea of finding out what are
the best predictors of longevity that we
can measure these 10 truths is to use
science to turn the lights on so you can
measure those 10 truths and then you can
see specifically where to focus mhm